and I just feel like I'm at the
basketball court waiting for you guys to
come through and then you guys aren't
coming to the park because you guys are
dating girls and you guys are [__]
going you guys are going to the movies
and making out with them all day and you
don't want to be like playing basketball
with me anymore cuz you finger B A girl
at the
[Music]
movie welcome back to to careful boys we
are afraid of everything today we're
talking about what we hate about JK oh
oh you were kidding I wasn't kidding
actually doing it right into it what the
hell happened there I was just pouring
water in cuz the protein started to dry
distractions that's what I hate
especially while I'm
hosting yeah three words all Steve day
you hate all Steve day you really do
hate all Steve day what do you hate
about all Steve day what do you hate
about it it's just nobody's focus and I
think everything just starts at the
leadership everything's always the top
there's no people are just [__]
taking breaks everywhere it's like you
think you're getting out at 6:30 we get
out at like 9 we've never gotten out at
9:00 we got out at 9: at last all Steve
day are we on track it's 1:00 are we on
track I think we're the cameras broke
last all Steve day that was the camera's
fault and then you guys had some guy
come in here making grills for I did I
didn't even schedu that hey Ryan's the
guy who told me to get it done I make
things happen even though the camer just
that's so like not believable like it
sounds crazy I'm out here ordering food
for us on time to make sure all day
works out okay that's why I have the
credit card here why you have to
schedule if we would have stayed on
schedule it would have happened
perfectly it was even mentioned in the
morning but why do you want to schedule
getting a [__] Dental mold in the
middle of a shoot and I just hate how
you guys always try to blame me when at
the end of day all ant day is nothing
but efficiency nobody says all ant day
first of all for when you're done that's
why that's the best part about such a
sick ass thing it's so true though we so
the this camera did break and you guys
were getting fitted for grills and I
still almost had you [__] out
of here blame I don't blame you I just
blame the day all Steve day it's just
always a wreck okay so happens to be
gets cursed with strange events yeah
just take gastrointestinal
issues sh a lot on all steeve days IBS
related issues [__] yeah I know and I
usually do before lunch I feel respected
yeah but that's blame my guts bro I my
guts blame my guts blame that Activia
you ate and then why does Alex
Resurrection always suggest lemonade for
lunch he has done a long time a long
time that used to be Michael too that's
what you hate about
JK and it's so expensive I hate that why
I hate that about JK that the food's
expensive lemonade lemonade Lonas for
cold salmon half of the food in this
[__] snacks is expired so you never
know what you're going to get it's
reaching over here okay
well you could thank Mr Resurrection for
that I didn't know you had so many
hateful feelings I got one I got one go
how how many times we' talk about
renovating the office never going to
happen it's a November thing now it is
is it yeah yeah yeah November no no nut
November is the time to do it okay okay
it's going to happen so focused it's
going to happen we're getting closer
yeah November is the time okay are we
are we filming in November nope that's
why got no we have November got it
that's one of the things that I feel
that I [__] absolutely [__] hate
about JK this used to be a full-time
thing for all of us mhm but because it
used to be the main priority but now
it's a part-time thing cuz we all have
other things going on and we get
together as like a treat right M now
that I'm back in this phase of my life
cuz I set up that other part and I can
prioritize this and I just feel like I'm
at the basketball court waiting for you
guys to come through and then you guys
aren't coming to the park cuz you guys
are dating girls and you guys are
[__] going you guys are going to the
movies and making out with them all day
and you don't want to be like playing
basketball with me anymore cuz you
rather [__] bigger B A girl at the
movie I would come every week if I
didn't live in Vegas time out you know
that's the first time you shared that I
didn't know that you were like back in
this phase why do you think the merch is
finally getting done you just well you
just told us that was the reveal dude he
doesn't communicate it see he the first
time he said it's only been a couple
weeks by the way well a month that's why
that's the feeling that I just been
having like oh you know what so you had
this feeling recently recently not like
I've been feeling this for 8 months I
already told Bart too like I'm on when
I'm in Hawaii phase like that's my
priority but when I'm back like it's on
we can do a lot of things right but I
feel like I didn't realize how much I
missed it is what I'm saying why we
taking November off let's I don't want
to take November off we got way too much
videos bro we can't afford to take it on
also the the yeah it was like to give
some breathing room for the finances so
we don't have to pay out
anybody got it but like I think I think
yeah there's a lot of things like that
that I that we can attend to now and I'm
I'm like oh you know what I missed this
[__] a lot like dude I want to make more
content or do some other [__] like I
don't know let's go let's make something
yeah and then take November off as hey
we've been talking about doing game
stuff I kind of like that quite a bit
let's do some game stuff do some game
stuff be fun we have we talk about a
long time that's the only thing I hate
okay not the only thing one of the 12
things I hate is every single time we're
like hey let's do this and then we don't
it's never going to happen pisses me off
man that does piss me off it's a slow
build it's a slow build dude but I also
understand why some some of the things
takes a long time I we do hit sometimes
still hit we do hit sometimes like you
know we got the you know we've had this
podcast set up for a few months now
episode 3 finally got into that's what I
hate the episode orders and how we can
never [__] understand when a video is
the hardest part makes no [__] sense
how does Netflix do
it how does episodes come out in order
like you shoot yourself in the foot
every episode like it's you do all the
work put it up it's oh well let's get
the minimum amount of views possible I
had Ryan hasawa stay with me recently in
Vegas right and I was like I I sat him
down we're drinking we're drinking
scotch and I'm like how the [__] does
the up [__] work just tell me what the
[__] happens and he's like yeah it's
like a you know it's like a thing it's
like this guy gets this and this guy
gets that still doesn't make any [__]
sense dude nobody knows nobody knows no
I'm still learning it well the the main
the main thing is is just it's mainly
because you don't meet up often enough
yep yeah but how about this let's take
November off how about this we all get
tattoos we're wearing that shirt and
like the first video that comes out
isn't us doing the tattoo thing or like
us in the video the off the Record where
we're talking about how we just got
tattoos but we're all wearing this
[__] shirt and we're all talking
about some
article but it was HT dude it was a
[__] Hot Topic it's like why and we
all have the tattoos and it's just like
we're talking about how a guy got in a
car accident oh we got a new guest and
then we put out [__] six videos of
new guest never explain who they are and
they barely are talking in those videos
and then now we're like hey meet this
person for the first time a month and a
half later I don't know but it's kind of
fun an entire season later it's almost
to the point where if we did do it right
the the audience would be like I missed
when it was all [__] up
cuz we're still it's probably the only
channel that does it that way or the
[__] anytime we have an actual
comedic flow we're just call back after
call back and it's like it's not going
to matter and someone goes uh we don't
do call backs here so shut up about it
please yeah that would be nice if it
came out in
order so we all feel this way we all
feel this way I know they can't figure
it out Joe's like I'm still learning how
it works hassa is like yes so it's like
this but he's like explaining like
molecular chemistry to to me I'm like I
don't [__] understand what the [__]
is I mean if you shoot 50 videos in a
weekend they're not going to come out
exactly right that's true but we shoot
them in order yeah if they just started
editing in order we literally filmed it
even then if the first so then the first
six would be in order and then after
that it's stockpiled to the dozens it's
like there's no way like I did an
article about freaking uh that I I've
looked at what you got to do is you got
to look at the stockpile you your heart
will drop at how irrelevant some these
things are and they still going to come
out and you're like oh God just delete
it you want to just delete it your
anti you're going to want to delete it
yourself bro Prince Charles is now King
Charles reacting to the Indiana Jones
movie trailer oh no upload it dude oh
upload it please upload it at least that
one we F we solve that mystery how the
[__] did that happen I don't know I
think it just gets pushed so far back
because we put more by who push Why by
who I don't know dude they get bottled
neck by The Who so the thing is we film
it in order they don't know so the
editor the editing team doesn't know
which videos are in the bank until they
open it so that we figured out that
problem on day the banker it's written
here that's why I got to press on this
side you got to do this and then when it
comes time for them to edit it it might
have been like a week or so cuz they do
all the priorities first all the Hot
Topics all them right so then the second
phase is like let me get to the videos
that are just like ambiguous time not
time sensitive that's why we had to come
up with the system of the warm topic Hot
Topic for the time sensitivities yeah or
else it's just going to be in the
database and then when they get to it
cuzz they won't be able to edit all of
it in a week so they need their time but
then that makes sense yeah so the but we
solved that issue so we won't have a
Indiana Jones react video in 2022 when
it was a 2021 the movie came out already
today's video is brought to you by
Uncommon Goods tired of buying the same
[__] [__] for the holidays
everyone's like oh no not that guy he
always buys that lame [__] at Target
check out some Independent Artists some
Independent Business people with unique
gifts this is really cool and it really
is a test to the name Uncommon Goods
this is very uncommon like where do you
actually see aoji donut kit and you know
they chose this because of my Asian face
and they knew that this will get all of
the Asian people happy which they are
not wrong by the way this this makes me
really happy it's a taste of Japan and
Asian people like to eat their gifts so
it's better to eat this than to eat some
socks that's right to get 15% off your
next gift go to uncommongoods.com sloff
thee that's uncommongoods.com off the
record for 15% off don't miss out on
this limited time offer uncommon good
we're all out of the ordinary part the
hard part too is that even though that's
the article like let's say the article
is something that could be anytime the
[__] we say around the article is time
sensitive like this the jokes we make
the stuff we say like it was so clever
in 20122 but we're seeing it now and D
they're year behind it's we look like
hacks because we're just like why are
they I mean the only way to solve it is
literally shoot every day and then have
them edit every day the piles that we
get but like less time so I think that's
one of the things of just like we're
here not enough right so a lot of these
issues yeah and then like even being
topical and like on time like on time
with certain things like if something
breaks out and if we have the ability to
just meet up together at that moment
film it go up cuz if we lived in Vegas
thing I hate about JK we don't it's not
everyone doesn't live in Vegas what the
[__] is up with you guys well you know
bring the pay rise back and uh we might
move you don't need to cuz you get
discount living there cheaper there and
we can do a pay lower and you'll still
make more money you still keep more
money but everybody always gets a moving
bonus when they got to move out of state
for their new job you know your bonus is
saving money on
taxes actually agree with that you are
the man there and F the man all right
it's like that video of Nick uh getting
shocked when I posted that people are
like where's when is the video coming
out I'm like it's not it's just sitting
in there is it's not going to come out
it's just sitting in there it has no
like date of when
sitting there that's what I love it's
sitting there we're waiting for a
grabber claw to come down and just scoop
it up we got chosen but sometimes it
slips and doesn't take anything is that
is that a patreon video no can we just
petition I don't know shoot two less
videos a session so we don't have
hundreds of backlog yeah maybe we could
Mark any of those novelty type videos as
a Hot Topic right yep anything can proba
do that yeah we should probably do that
I like how that's the only way we'll
ever see him again but then doesn't it
cost more to do that yep so let's not
fix the system let's just abuse it in
different ways like the government you
know what I mean but it's worth it it's
worth it because it has a novelty to it
people like it okay let's go back to
regular things we hate about JK the
thing is when a novelty video gets made
it gets filed as just the article so
whoever's looking at it doesn't know
it's novel they just go oh the article
is this I don't even know if anyone's
watching what it even is y well they
don't watch it till the last moment yeah
so like's so after it it is it's it's up
they it's it's watched for the purpose
of making sure that we don't say
anything that can cancel us too hard to
the point where our whole Channel goes
down or there isn't any copyright or
whatever [__] up or there's no editing
errors so like the sound dropped at this
point or like there's like a whole blank
thing missing for one minute then they
have to go back and re-edit we're going
to need to have you guys shoot like an
intro a new intro like a disclaimer it's
like hey welcome to JK Classics we shot
this over a year ago so things might be
out of context JK Classics oh that' be a
good playlist you know I think there's
actually a channel called JK Classics
where we uploaded old videos we also
probably need a new channel trailer just
a thought oh yeah dude we definitely
need new channel Traer a theory that I
have yeah something that maybe we feel
like we're a part of even just a banner
that has the rest of us on it oh that'd
be cool wait we have a channel trailer
yeah but it's just you and
Bart oh yeah let's do Channel trailers
that's a great idea
guys hey I'm back from Hawaii now let's
get stuff done let's do it he's back you
can also get more official photos taken
like I can have someone come and just do
like actual cool idea cuz we have
nothing really out there but that's you
know kind of hard when we only meet up 4
days a month and and you just we're in
and out and we can't do anything else
outside of that we can get fitted for
grills we can get some pictures taken
during lunch let's do it doing all Ste
we one or the other yeah we we could do
we could do that all right we'll do it
during all all photos promos
during we're leaving here at 10 p.m.
part's going to get aass here for we'll
do more girls too especially surgeries
if you guys need to do any major
surgeries do my lasic surgery here you
should have you should have a cleaning
lady come in vacuum yes all that we
usually have a cleany person come while
we're not here it be good if we did it
dur all I think that's a good idea since
we're all here I like JK even more now
you it's even funnier when you talk cuz
I have a friend who's he's a channel
manager at like a different uh gaming
channel it's like pretty famous and this
dude loves watching our stuff and he
also loves nitpicking everything our
system is and he's constantly saying me
[__] like why do you guys do this and
I'm like I don't know what's his
critiques yeah why don't we just have
him here just [__] ripping us apart
and if we can make all of the
adjustments he'll be like thank you he
would love to make us a whole L take
that list and we just dump it in the
trash thanks for nothing my favorite
thing that will happen and I can't wait
for this is now Joe's like I'm back I'm
ready I'm engaged we're going to take
November off we're going to be back here
say January and Joe's like I had to go
back to June
B what if that actually happen will
happen wait so what happens if like
something huge goes on in November like
like Hawaii gets nuked or some [__] like
some crazy [__] news story we'll talk
about it in March
yeah you know there's going to be a big
story in November there is we're going
to miss it yep we're going to miss all
the Thanksgiving dud we could jump on
Skypes or some [__] I mean we talked
about this last year too yeah we did
during Co we're like yeah we should do a
[__] we did do a Skype ver uh episode
that that wasn't an episode that was L
like a we shot a version of that to add
to our or Vegas that was that was the
one time we did another skit when I said
how JK news is an abbreviation of all of
us and I and I got to say I don't know
if that was a great appropriation of our
funds I thought yeah no more Trump Tower
thought it was good that's true that was
a blast damn you we probably should have
got a circus circus suite for for 50
bucks we could have done that 70 bucks
get the top floor that's true dude let's
do that next next year yeah that sounds
fun are you guys down I'm kind of down
okay I'm going to find the best Suite in
the shittiest Hotel oh my God and we're
going to do a Vegas damn it you guys
baby I don't want to do that on location
review location head buug time you do
know that when we actually get into that
suite and we're shooting it doesn't look
like anything
different dude that sweet looked like
[__] when we filmed in there those
videos look like [__] it was like hell
it was wild when I posted a reel made
from those videos cuz I'm like oh I
might as well pull from those cuz
they're you know I don't have any reels
I made one people were like damn JK
really going downhill like it looked
like a negative it did it looked like
someone's are they filing from someone's
house like we can't afford to be in this
office anymore it's hilarious it looked
less than this somehow to people it was
the lighting yeah the Trump Tower was
such a great move though it was really
fun I think that's the exact thing that
we're complaining about right now but
the room itself didn't look like Trump
anything it just looked like a room I
think the the the the execution just
didn't play out the way we thought in
our minds but to me it's like the tattoo
thing we committed it was fun to a I
like cuz the joke was dude imagine we're
going to JK at at the Trump Tower right
but then like we did the actual thing
but it doesn't look funny yeah I had fun
if it was all gold walls or something
you know what I mean hey but the my
favorite part about that is the is the
black lady that called us all Jabba
walkies that was
F she was like are y'all Jaba walkies
and I'm like uh and then she goes oh is
that racist and I'm like not really cuz
he actually is he actually teally
is Anthony you going to say what you
hate about JK you a little okay I I hate
when bark gets up too early I don't like
that